top female athletes in the tennis world
here in Henderson competing at the
Henderson Tennis Open it's a USDA pro
circuit women's event with players here
from Switzerland England Japan Slovakia
Egypt and many other countries
[Music]
Sophie Chang hoping to score a portion
of the sixty thousand dollars up for
grabs at this year's Henderson tennis
open at Dragon Ridge Country Club I'm 25
and I've turned pronos 18 so I've been
playing on the circuit for a little
while now she's competing against nearly
70 up and coming tennis professionals
from around the globe a good portion
have world rankings number 100 to 300
director of tennis Adolf Huddleston we
have young players that are looking to
establish themselves on a tour and we
have some of those that are still
playing and using this as a tune-up to
maybe qualify for the Australian coming
up in January these athletes stay with a
regular host family the keeners they
keep me who become their home away from
home which is needed as tournament
Players like Sophie are always on the go
just recently this year I got to travel
a good bit internationally for me so
that was fun I went to Germany England
and Tokyo for us creating a venue where
they love coming and when they see it on
the calendar like this is where we want
to go it's a 60 000 Challenger so it's
quite lucrative as far as the the steps
that it takes to come up to through the
ranks and of course you can't beat Las
Vegas it's a very fun city to play in a
great atmosphere and you get to go and
see some fun shows that's really fun for
me I'm not a big gambler but a gamble on
court
we wish her all the best the Henderson
Tennis Open wraps up this Sunday at
Dragon Ridge Country Club with the
finals the athletes range in age from 16
to 32 years of age